the hall-of-famer tennis broadcaster
winner of seven majors and a new book
out called but seriously now available
online or ever books are sold making
some headlines here John did you know
that you had made headlines I didn't
know until I got back from LA last night
and I was watching some of the
late-night shows it just before that I
wanted to catch a little sports
highlights and then there's a John
McConnell says that Serena Williams
would be the I'm like oh my god
have you ever said that about a enough
maybe the numbers are slightly different
and I'm not the only one but this has
been said about a hundred times so I
don't know all of a sudden they're like
he said something outrageous and I love
Serena by the way and I they forget the
other parts but she's the greatest
player ever and all the other nice
things I've said about her over the
years can I play the audio oh sure okay
this is long this is from NPR where John
is being interviewed just to put this in
context of how it came up so thank you
yeah I appreciate that this is like you
know being the Trump and Co me or
something get their gates there are
tapes yeah wait they were taping you
John they were here that was on here's
John McEnroe let's talk about Serena
Williams you say she is the best female
player in the world in the book best
female player ever no question some
wouldn't qualify it some would say she's
the best player in the world
why qualify it oh she's not you mean the
best player in the world period yeah
best tennis player in the world you know
why why say female player well because
if she was a if she played the men's
circuit she'd be like 700 in the world
do you think so yeah that doesn't mean I
don't think Shirin is like an incredible
player I do but there's you know the
reality of what what would happen on a
given day the Serena could beat some
some players I believe because she's so
incredibly strong mentally but if she
had to just just play the circuit for
the men's circuit that would be an
entirely different story
so maybe at some point a women's tennis
player you know can be better than
anybody I mean I just I haven't seen it
in any other sport and I haven't seen in
in tennis and I suppose anything's
possible at some stage
why do people have a problem with what
you said I don't know they don't talk
about in other sports I suppose when
Riggs played Billie Jean back in the 70s
its prompted this idea that we should
keep doing it it hasn't really happened
on O'Connor's played Martina Navratilova
about 20-something years ago gave her he
only had one servant she of the
double-doubles a lien beater and over
the course of time people including our
nel president wasn't president at the
time they've offered me sums of money to
play Serena or Venus I don't know why
I'm always the God that they want to
play the old fart now that can you still
beat Serina but at any rate I believe I
have some ability left and I had pride
when I played and they could ask why
don't they ask her to play Roger Federer
or you know Rafael Nadal on clay see how
that goes yeah but would you play her
for amount of money you know I never
really thought that that was something
that the mix the apples and oranges I
should probably suggest now that might
not be a bad idea if everyone's all up
in arms about it what happen we have the
women play in the men's circuit and
we'll see what happens let them all play
for the next two years and see what the
rankings are and as far as you know I
talk about in this book a little bit
obviously you haven't read it down but
that's okay it's got it I know I just
got it a minute ago so I forgive you
yeah but I love the pictures they're the
kids the kid my own kids they are for
girls in cue boys so I've become a great
feminist over the years oh and it would
be happy about that but they don't think
I can beat her and there's a lot of
people that don't think I can beat her
at this stage and I'm not quite as sure
as I was a couple years ago she's a
tremendous player and it weren't a great
athletes period of the 20th 20th century
for sure this is this 700 numbers would
bother people maybe that's what it is I
mean what do you think she'd be are you
like sports you follow tennis what
number do you think she'd be if okay
we're talking about who could she be if
I pulled out the two hundred and
fiftieth ranked player right now I I
think she has a great chance because
she's been in that moment the 250 ranked
person has it so I want to see what you
do with the build-up to it the height to
it you get out there center court now
I'm not talking about I completely agree
which is what I said yeah if you listen
to what I said I said she could beat
handful of people who would choke get
you know overwhelmed by the occasion and
there's other times where she wouldn't
be feeling it and there'd be a 17 year
old guy who's the number one guy and you
know it's one part of the world that
would beat her and there's college
players I get pros at my club I got
thirty seven pros at my club at
Randall's Island and they're sick I mean
I like to get out and playing there's
six or seven guys in a given day maybe
more I'd lose to and there'd be a
thousand people I'd lose to now and also
I mean you got to bring in if you
actually want to analyze this is she
going to play best of five no no in the
majors for starters I mean how would
that go over she's never done that it's
like me I play a set now against Roddick
on the Champions Tour and I'm exhausted
so now they want me to play two out of
three it would be two and I maybe can
play tea sets I have to be TAS arena
whoever else in two sets because I fall
over in the other set but I hate when we
start to do this compare and contrast I
do Cyril Clement and what are we doing
in basketball or what are they do it in
hockey or why don't they do it in
running or boxing for that matter that's
where they at least be the same weight
class they you know you'd think it'd be
a level or playing field why is it
always tennis and it's always McEnroe
that gets caught in the middle of this
it drives me crazy well in fairness to
you you got led down that road I did I
don't thank you thank thank you for your
playing that because it people why did
you bring that up you just want to sell
books up I guess I do want to like I'd
like to books and hopefully be
successful but that's not the reason I
wasn't planning on bringing it up and
I've been in there five different
occasions when my kids were born and
it's a magnificent experience I'm sure
you well know yourself and I wish Serena
the best and whatever she tweet I think
she tweeted cuz I don't tweet but
whatever it was you know let me don't
trust me out I'm just having a kid leave
me up there I want nothing for the beste
Serena she's been you know without
Serena and to a lesser extent Venus the
you met the sport of tennis in America
really be struggling but the the
argument could be the most decorated
tennis player of all time if you want to
do it in that context then you know most
successful story is one of the great
stories in tennis history this the
sister
I mean my brother and I played a couple
times and I think that Venus was a great
help to de su in his career the way she
handled it because I would have jumped
off the Empire State Building
did you loose you no of course not but
um in practice but we only played a
couple times but I knew it was weird and
difficult it should have been and she
handled it amazing well in Serena's and
then I mean she's one of the truly great
athletes in the last hundred years and
their story is amazing there you go
that's all you needed today but you know
I've said that before you threw out the
700 number that's what got you in
trouble what are you going to say when
you see her when you have a baby gift
for her and you see her what do you say
I'm gonna buy her seven hundred roses
who said okay I like that well wait is
it six hundred ninety nine or is it
seven hundred could she beat the 700d
take seven hundred people there's
probably ten people or fifteen possibly
on a given day that she could have some
success with because of the very reason
she's been there and she's been under
pressure situations way more than they
have but there's no question but I will
hopefully it will move past this I think
this will all be history in a day or so
that's the good part I've been through
some things with Serena mostly good and
sometimes this comes up and it's
annoying when when it happens but I
suppose it's better than not being
talked about at all I suppose and you
know and and good night everyone so you
can thanks for Evelyn who's the best
men's player of all time the best men's
player of all time for would be Roger
Federer with a slight edge over Rafael
Nadal I would have given Rafa a couple
years ago but consistency overall Rogers
been there more I know that Rafa's
records better if Roth had won that
match in Australia where he was three
one up in the fifth and the finals that
would have maybe had me inch slightly
ahead again but you know both of them
are amazing Rod Laver was my idol
growing up so I always put him in the
mix Sampras was the toughest guy I've
ever had to play against only a couple
times he would be in that group of four
maybe and then after that it's hopefully
well hopefully I'm still somewhere and I
know my ranking is dropping
pretty-pretty painfully hopefully I'm in
the top ten still what about if Borg
heads played continued to play he
retired about 26 25 or said that amazing
yeah what it was amazing he sad to me
because he was my great rival and then
he walked away from the game and I kept
trying to get him to come back I was
like look we made each other better this
is an incredible time in tennis don't do
this and she said someday you'll
understand
I've had that twice my ex-wife told me
that that she said someday you'll
understand you'll even appreciate what
I'm doing and Borg said it and I think
both times it's been it's too bad in the
case of Tatum I lucked out because I
went Patty Smyth the past 23 years and I
did get the second chance that I didn't
think I'd have in borås case I sort of
had except that he wasn't coming back
but I never felt it was the same in the
sport in a way again he would just he
look like this there was a cat-like
quality to it you know when he went to
Glen Boleyn they started to grow the
beard like he was that intimidating at
all they had banned the whole what the
look was amazing you know he I just
wanted to look a little bit like him as
good as him there's no question that
there was this aura I noticed when I was
14 or 15 when he was playing when his
first Wimbledon's outside the locker
room they were literally a 250 girls
screaming like beating the equivalent of
tennis version of Beatlemania I want to
be a tennis player please God let me
have just one twentieth of this did you
ever have women outside your locker room
screaming for you my mom was screaming I
didn't did you have I didn't have I did
not have people screaming at me I mean
maybe screaming and the different types
of screaming it not to say that there
weren't some people around and that we
didn't have it wasn't fortunate in that
way but nowhere near the level Bjorn I
mean it was like when I would used to be
with my late great buddy Vitas
Gerulaitis they'd roll out the red
carpet for him it's 30 or 54 I'd be I
couldn't get in I'd be on the number
five in the world I get the hell out of
here so I need to develop more hunger
but I thought to myself listen I just
got a one of the best things ever about
Vitas I played in my first major I won
in the finals we were both two kids from
Queens and that was weird because I
looked up to Vitas as a kid he where
same tennis academy so I certainly
didn't really want to beat him but I
wanted to win and then afterwards for
him 20 for me 20 having to have some
upstart sort of bypass him and that
after the match he said what are you
doing later because and I figured he
probably be going like studio 54 and I
knew I go whatever you're doing because
I know what you're doing is a hell of a
lot better than what I was going to do
yeah but you said you couldn't get into
studio 54 and Andy Warhol ruined your
sex life you know you know that papers
come a bit of an exaggeration about yeah
when you get after studio 54 some of
these parties you go to a friend's place
where you figured okay you can unwind
and really relax let your guard down but
54 was crazy 54 is crazy but I'm talking
about after the after party after that
you go to some friend's house and you
could let the guard down you don't
expect it a studio 54 outside but you
could let it down you're hoping you
might get lucky and then here's this guy
with that fright wig taking a picture
and I'm like what is he doing that's
three in the morning did he ever point
out in the he did paint me and my
ex-wife there's a couple of couple
paintings he did where he came over he
said everything's fantastic
everything's great if he didn't say that
you were the biggest jerk that ever
lived because he said and fantastic is
fantastic and I was like look I don't
underst quite understand this guy but
what do I know I mean look what's if you
walk down the streets in New York now
and you just ask ask the average person
name two artists they're going to say
Pablo Picasso and Andy Warhol yes oh
he's he's their pantheon of artists do
you still have the painting I have one
of them I actually look for a third
because I had three kids with my ex-wife
I couldn't get one because I heard
sometimes he ran off others I ended up
selling one a charity I raised a lot of
money and I gave it to Habitat for
Humanity because I was a big Jimmy
Carter fan and I didn't feel it be right
to take the money because that's when we
got divorce I said to Tatum I said look
there's two of these why don't you take
one and I'll take the other and she said
she didn't want one oh I'm like okay at
that time it wasn't necessarily
considered and how valid be it was
valuable it wasn't I'm sure she didn't
want to look at me and I also it's not
something I can hang in the living room
now the other one was had
sort of sits in storage yeah so I sold
that one I thought this I get this call
from Jimmy Carter because he was a big
hero of mine and he'd say come down
let's get together and then he I got a
letter eventually sort of to whom it may
concern letter I was like and Patti said
to me look you can't ever expect
anything and if you expected or think
that that's just because you you know
donated four hundred thousand dollars
which seemed like a lot of money but the
price of this painting hundred nine
thousand dollars but it didn't work out
but that's okay I learned a lesson from
it we'll come back we'll talk a little
bit more about the book some music
replay in that one of your favorite
topics to talk about replay replay uh
yeah we can talk about that yeah I mean
if I would have been a we have a lot
better player we have an idea but I'll
put in more boring
we have Willie and you brought your
guitar I did bring it you you're the
only guy that asked me to bring it most
people say don't bring the guitar your
wife and I they don't play yes all the
time
okay says now she's at least this don't
sing I'll let you play some guitar just
don't sing so I may even possibly sing
no no I want you to sing unless you
unless you play guitar don't you know I
don't oh no no I don't okay but I know
good guitar is when I hear but then
you're not going very long a nickel
minute the book is called but seriously
it's available online weber books are
sold we're back with more from john mack
after this
[Music]
John McEnroe John Beck yes it is I mean
that's for me that was okay actually you
were you were cringe leave it or not
you're listening to yourself your create
a little tell me a heard Cobain I mean
this that's one of these that song
I mean changed a lot of things I did 25
years ago John's new book is but
seriously now available online and
wherever books are sold all right we
have a TV show idea for it whatever what
if we went back to look at all of the
club you know points that you argued
about we had replay there and just to
see if you actually were telling you
were could we do that I'm fair yeah why
not that's not a bad idea
well what we did I know an idea are just
not a bad idea it's a good idea I like
that idea but I'd like to know if you
were actually you know accurate here
that that you were the one that we
should have been probably there's seven
hundred most accurate guy in the world
but but there are moments where you
probably knew that that it was out or
you know that you shouldn't be arguing
but that's on the seamless tour now that
I don't let me do that and we yeah we
definitely that's I get paid extra for
this now you do yeah so that way I have
to do this we they encouraged me to do
this even when I know damn well I'm
wrong and you know sometimes these guys
use it to get get a little breather you
know when they've had a long it's not
just for the call I mean most of the
time the players know they're there
right or they know what what it's going
to be beforehand there's only a handful
of calls and it's set but you ever try
to get into somebody's head when you're
actually younger doing well I always
figured that if a guy was going to be
bothered that much by me if I said to an
umpire you mother you know yes what are
the odds of him giving me the next call
I would say slim and none
right yeah so the other guy should be
happy that I've just told this guy that
mother wears army boots him and so I was
surprised at the way people with how
he's just doing this to try to throw
them off if that's all it takes to throw
someone off with all the trash talking
here in football or basketball the other
sports come on did you ever get close to
fighting somebody I wanted to fight
Connors a few times I figured that would
be one of the few guys I could beat you
could beat up Don I thought I could I'm
not saying I don't know I know he's a
bit of a street fighter but I was
willing to get bloodied for that not on
the court but like me teaming and off
the court anyway I was going to strangle
this guy absolutely and I'm sure that he
felt the same way and we respect each
other now and we can laugh about it but
at the time we definitely didn't like
each other and there were a few times
where I was like I'm gonna walk up this
court I'm going to punch him in the face
were you similar we were similar he was
someone who looked at me and didn't want
me to take his turf and we were like two
Bulls going at it and the opposite of me
and board or hand and board and it was
electric thrown away I mean every time I
looked at Connors I said to myself am I
trying as hard as this guy I mean I had
the ultimate respect for what he brought
to the table I kept checking to see if
he was he had a twin brother named
Petros
but at any rate the haircut given
haircut all cut the way they played
everything about him but the intensity
he brought was I had to improve it that
to try harder to dig deeper that's the
only way I could play with him so he
definitely taught me a lot in that
respect right you brought your guitar
can I take my jacket off yeah you can
yeah you got yours because I got a lot
of buttons so you got your Keith
Richards t-shirt on yeah but you haven't
played with the stones of you and I
haven't played with the stones I played
with Chrissie Hynde of the pretenders
once when the she opened for the stones
at Madison Square Garden which was
awesome so that's the closest I've ever
come to playing although Bill Wyman the
old bass player the stones did actually
had me in his hotel room a couple times
and try to teach me to get to our end or
bass because he was a bass Miller so
that's about that I'm better as a guitar
player that I was that's not you know
the bar is extremely low than when I
started so I'll give it a shot you know
I let me let me grab this on you
grab your you could talk what you know
this this is a song by a green dead
alright are you gonna sing I'm going to
try to sing hopefully I'm in tune you
know the song good riddance
[Music]
okay so what I'm going to do I did this
especially for you guys you we show it
on time or we got a minute or two
okay yeah because I wrote this
especially for you yeah I thought about
this last night when I came into LA and
I thought they'd be appropriate this is
a song I wrote it's about it's a Green
Day song but I wrote it with Nick Nick
words the New York Knicks
oh I like okay okay here we go here we
go
[Music]
another turning point for come in the
road
would have do with Mal own now now the
Phil doesn't wanna stay home I still
believe or leave our can hope the next
don't keep being the butt of everyone's
jokes something unpredictable
me and coconut will be tried but still
don't trade poor thing is tonight
[Music]
but Phil don't trade forcing his tonight
thank you well done well done that's
going to be a hit I think it's got some
legs you know I don't know how the
Knicks are you know I still got hope in
it's a tough one right now but this
whole thing has gotten a bit crazy but
I'm a long-suffering Knick fan I love it
I thought they were going to win 50
games this year I was wrong about that
I've got a soft spot for my buddy
you know Yannick know is a great buddy
of mine and yellow keen to be at the
Knicks was amazing I know it's been
torturous for him and you there when
Oakley gonna head out I was there okay
he pushed me on the shoulder he would
say hey John how are you know Charles I
couldn't believe it he looked natty he's
tremendous shape as always introducing
my son and the next thing you know
things just spiraled totally out of
control I didn't know what had happened
I heard the commotion because the
security guy came over and I said to
Kevin I said I think someone's heckling
Phil Jackson because we didn't know what
was happening but they told Jim Dolan
that someone you know being heckled and
the next thing you know well you have to
go to commercial right are you being
you're not gonna be subpoenaed here I
don't I don't know is there I know the
next day I Charles I - Johnny Mack he
knows what happened am i way to sell
throw me in the middle of this okay all
of a sudden you climb so Jim and the
guys are the next they have it's amazing
you know amazingly lucky that I get a
you know a couple times a year a handful
you go to the Knicks it's a guy who grew
up a Knicks fan and to see Charles
Oakley going on it was the whole thing
was obviously terrible for everyone
these John McEnroe the book is called
but seriously is now available online in
Weber book system it's great that you
came in thanks for having me Dan and
light if you have an encore you know I'm
gonna I'm going to leave you can go out
of sight it's better to have to leave
okay
less less is more isolated yeah yeah so
don't say anything about Sarina right
now I should have but the second verse
would it should have been to read
the book is but seriously John macro
John thank you for coming him the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience